[Music]
okay everyone this is my spoiler review
of the euphoria season 2 finale
i got to watch this one live with all of
you people we didn't get screeners for
this so i was bracing myself all day to
watch this i was very excited to watch
it i sat through the hbo max crash with
all of you pretty impressive that's how
many people are watching the show
reminds me of the days of game of
thrones where hbo go would crash uh we
all remember hbo go i kind of uh missed
that name but anyway i
you know had a lot of thoughts last week
about this lexi play and before we even
get to lexi's play in this episode let's
just address the elephant in the room
which is that scene with elliott aka
dominic fike
i mean
i was just
waiting
for that to end it just kept going and
going and going and i actually think i
would be would have been less pissed off
at it if he wasn't a music artist in
real life you know it felt so corporate
it felt like i was being sold something
it felt like i was watching a music
video that would be attached to euphoria
somewhere else to sell a single that we
go download his music on spotify it
irked me i hate stuff like that and i
absolutely hated that scene and also it
was just awkward and not even like
earned between these two characters
especially with elliot to have that big
moment in the finale and to awkwardly
look in rue's eyes that long i was like
this is just ridiculous i did not like
that
i think a lot of people agree with me on
that one because wow
i i just don't know how stuff like that
gets through but maybe dominic fike is a
genius businessman has a great agent and
gets that signed in on the contract for
me in the show you know who knows uh
play my music basically so
yeah cringe so anyway i had said my
thoughts about the play with lexi and
that it was strange that they had chose
to put that in the penultimate episode
it's even showing you how much it slowed
down everything even for the finale here
because i feel like these last two
episodes have just
been brought to a halt with this lexi
play it's forcing everything to stop
it's forcing everything to be in the
same kind of area and i think that
actually backfires and hurts it here and
like i said
this story that they focused in on with
lexi and then kind of connecting it a
lot to rue which i liked finally
reminding us of their friendship and
having these themes where they can bond
over with their issues in life and
again this would have just been great in
the middle of a season like there should
be two more episodes to this season this
doesn't feel like a finale and
parts of it do right like the finale
type stories we're getting is what's
happening with fez what's happening with
nate but man some of this just felt all
over the place in particular
bizarre things happening like everyone's
waiting for this big moment cassie
blowing up they literally made it the
cliffhanger last week and we literally
see
her head get bashed into a wall
by maddie and then they're in the
bathroom and everything's cool i would
have loved to seen how the hell they
went from that moment to just chilling
in the bathroom and i always say i'm not
a fan of the susie character she's the
worst mom ever i'm still trying to
figure out how her daughter runs away
getting attack goes missing and she
doesn't even look for her she just sits
down and continues watching lexi's play
yes i get she's supporting her
daughter's play but literally her
daughter is literally getting attacked
by someone does not care it's just
frustrating it's the weirdest character
to me and
you know there's a lot going on in this
episode and a lot of people talk about
the crazy stuff that happened with
ashtray now ashtray makes a silly
mistake but he is a kid so i can justify
it where he decides to go for custer's
throat when it was really fae who was
doing the smart thing by
you know covering for fez letting him
know what was happening but then
throwing laurie under the bus on the
phone for the cops that would have been
the perfect out for them why even kill
custer you know so they needed fez's
word they needed phase word or ashes
where they weren't going to get it now
because
you know faye warned him so they didn't
need to kill the guy so the kid made a
silly mistake but for people were
confused about why he did we did with
holding up in the bathroom it's because
he wasn't gonna let fez go down for him
now
i think this did come off a little too
shock like trying to shock people for a
finale having ashtray be shot and it
just didn't land for me and i think
that
it just was all this hype of what's
gonna happen with fez and you know he's
late for the play and he sadly sees his
brother get shot in front of him but
i don't know i just thought it wasn't
that exciting a lot of this finale i was
tuning out in my head i was bored and
even in the scene that should be like
edge of your seat it was in a sense but
it also wasn't because it was just kind
of all silly to me and i know i'm being
hard here but again this is how i feel
and this is a show i usually really like
but i have a lot of issues with it when
it kind of gets all over the place and i
don't feel like sam levinson still with
a clear vision with the show and this
show this season in particular feels
like it's just going episode by episode
and that there isn't this clear plan and
i'm worried again like i said about the
constant circle you're feeling about
this show and not forward momentum and
you know it looks like maddie and cassie
are going to find some kind of piece
here bonding over not liking nate and
then it's like okay and then they
russian jewels having any kind of moment
with rue
and
rue's saying you know she's sober but
still not really for her yet so we know
she's gonna relapse at some point again
the show and yes that's the life what's
realistic with drug addicts but
where is it all still making me excited
i have no excitement for season three
i'm sitting here like okay
like great thank you like i i think
there is a problem too or sam levinson
he's so talented but
he's so in his own head sometimes i
think and he's forgetting the part of
creating where you're making a show
right and it's like you also just think
how is this affecting my audience you
know how is this also entertaining it's
not just what am i artistically feeling
it's how is this speaking to different
people and maybe i get that argument now
that maybe he needs another voice in
that writer's room somebody just like to
just steer the ship a bit because i feel
like he's just a he's a mad genius in a
sense but with no structure no guidance
that's what frustrates me and i think
that needs to change for future seasons
for sure and
uh i mean that's also a bizarre thing to
her
i appreciate shows doing something
differently and you know what's
euphoria's claim to fame is like you
don't know what's going to happen with
the show it's so hard to define what
even genre it is where it falls but
i do get annoyed that
how do i go from this play stuff that
feels very degrassy to stuff that feels
very breaking bad it's so
such a switch that if you didn't know
the show euphoria and you saw someone
watching it and they flip between the
play scenes and then this ashtray scene
you'd be like did you put on a different
show like it has to still feel connected
enough and justified enough tonally
where i think it's actually too extreme
where
i'm like i'm getting annoyed because i'm
someone like i've said i really enjoyed
the episode with the intervention right
and episode one where it did feel that
very ozark breaking bad feel and i think
he does that great sam evanson and i'm
sitting there through all the play stuff
wanting more of that and i feel like i'm
getting bored because my head is
somewhere else i'm in a different world
with that stuff and then i'm back at
this play and
watching just a cat fight like i don't
know that's what just frustrates me
where i think season one just did a
better job of keeping some consistent
tone there keeping better structure and
again showing showing and not feeling
like it was going episode by episode as
it was going along so
you know it's not all bad here i think
that
there's a lot of good stuff going on
here that need to happen with lexi and
roo
it's just the timing of where it is in
the season is frustrating um it almost
feels like they just wedged in like you
know what we haven't done much with lexi
in the show in general this is her time
to shine but to give her the penultimate
and the finale for a character we barely
knew about and just overloading us with
her her story actually really taking the
center and then sprinkling in the roof
stuff really is frustrating and and
that's gonna go too have we forgotten
about the lori's story and how how is
rouge is fine now and lori's okay with
her
robbing her of this money uh okay so
there's no consequence for that right so
and that's not even addressed with
anybody in her life
really frustrating why am i getting so
mad i don't really know
but
you know i think
overall this was the weakest episode to
me because i just wasn't buying it i
just wasn't enjoying it i didn't like
what it was doing so i'm giving this one
a 7.1 i think it's disappointing and i
think the last two episodes of this
season were very disappointing i thought
there was a really strong point where we
had this new labyrinth song introduced
with the church singing and from where
that went on to then the intervention
episode was just brilliant to me and i'm
so disappointed that this kind of just
felt sloppy these last three and this
again this decision to do the play just
i just feel like if the play wasn't in
this moment or if it was a different
episode this would change everything but
everything revolved around this freaking
play and i think it just took away so
much from a show that could have just
shined here and finished strong and
that's what again it's too reflective
right it's halting it it's a reflective
play it's just someone reflecting almost
on their own show now i like this stuff
with cal
and
nate you know nate actually
brings cal to the cops here and has the
usb drive so he's gonna go
to jail for his crimes the father of the
underage stuff and then
you know
again i don't think still there was
enough time and even in the end here
with nate and cal i don't think there's
enough time a lot of people we still
have no story with cat um
so that's the frustration look not every
mouth is gonna get fed here but
it just feels so just like detached even
from three episodes ago what show i'm
watching now so
uh but yeah we'll see where it goes i'm
i've told you my score for this for the
season as a whole i would have said i
was excited to hope that season two will
be better than season one because i love
the premiere i love those two episodes
in the middle
but i do think it's actually now weaker
than season one uh so season score
because again we such high highs here
and such low lows for me personally so i
would say season score for this season
i'd still give it about an 8.3 but sam
levinson's gotta tighten things up
structure it look i love art i love
anything that's super hard c2 and that
visually the cinematographer is amazing
here right but the script's got to be
just better it has to be better um
uh let me know what you thought though
what season you liked better what you
thought of the finale if you agree with
me disagree with me i'd love to hear
your thoughts thank you so much for
joining me my euphoria reviews i really
appreciate you subscribe to my channel
it helps me in so many ways you have no
idea
and if you really love what i do here if
you become a member today yeah exclusive
perks and it'll help me do this
full-time one day and please follow me
at steve arley show on twitter instagram
and tick tock for more of me and i'll
see you next time